what is feminism in your
opinion great question I don't want to
say what it is in my opinion what I want
to say rather is how do we actually use
the word anyone can just make up a new
definition what I really wanted to think
about was let's listen to other people
and see what definition fits actual
usage and the definition that I offer is
this one feminism is the view that our
society generally treats men more fairly
than women feminism is the view that our
than women uh if you look at official
definitions they will say things like
it's just the view that men and women
should be treated equally what I point
out in my essays we got public opinion
data where we ask a whole lot of people
and guess what almost everyone who says
they're not a feminist still thinks that
men and women should be treated equally
so that cannot possibly be the actual
definition it's more of an argumentative
definition like calling your newspaper
truth and then if someone disagrees with
you say oh you're against
truth right okay so it's a lexical
Brazilian jiu-jitsu yes right I
understand why are you not a fan of it
you wrote a book for your 10-year-old
daughter called don't be a feminist uh
that is correct I mean honestly it just
comes down to the empirics is it really
true that our society generally treats
men more fairly than women uh what I did
in that essay just go over all of the
main complaints that people have to this
effect and try to see does the evidence
really hold up um I begin by saying look
you can't just say that someone's
treated unfairly because the performance
is unequal by that standard I've been
treated unfairly by the Olympics because
I don't have any medals what you really
need to do is to go and compare
someone's performance to the treatment
some the treatment they've gotten to
their performance uh here's an economist
the natural thing to start with is with
earnings and Career Success there's been
a lot of work on this and the standard
punchline is it's very easy to explain
the gender gap in Career Success by
differences in things like the number of
hours that men and women work the majors
that they select in college just the
unpleasantness of the jobs so if we go
through some fairly standard differences
and and of course as well as just your
priorities in life is the job the top
priority in your life or there other
things that you're balancing and when
you put all that together you can very
easily statistically explain almost all
of the difference in earnings between
men and women so that's one that I talk
about quite a bit then I also go over
things
like complaints about inequities and
dating right this is where I point out
there is a very strong tendency among
feminists to go and compare the average
woman to the most successful men which
is not really a sensible comparison what
do they comparing body count ah no you
know thing you know things more like you
know how good is the Romantic life of
the very most successful men versus the
very most successful women right so if
you compare like the lives of a
Hollywood actor to a Hollywood actress
and say now the Hollywood actors have it
better right you know no no there's no
female you know no no actress is like
Leonardo DiCaprio just going for with
regards to what they're mating success
yes so you know things like mating
success or let's see of course also in
jobs is saying like a certain percentage
of the CEOs are men are you larger than
50% percentage CEOs are men and what I
say is look if we're going to do that we
need to compare both the top and the
bottom and there again there is
overwhelming evidence that men are over
represented at the bottom as well as the
top men are much more likely to be in
prison much more likely to commit
suicide much more likely to be homeless
much more likely to be in cels to have
never been on a date so you put all this
together it's like it's not in any sense
that men in general are treated more
fairly than women in general rather what
we have is that there is a greater
spread which again if anything based
upon normal ideas of insurance the group
that has the smaller spread is the
advantage group what you mean when you
say smaller spread and bigger spread uh
well for things like uh you are less
likely to be far from average so for
example highs spread would be a group
that has a lot of billionaires and a lot
of homeless people men a low spread
would be a group that has fewer
billionaires and fewer homeless people
which would be women right or similarly
you could go and look at the top of
achievement and say men are over
represented in Nobel prizes in being
best-selling authors right U like in
being famous composers that's all true
says well while we're at it how about we
go and take a look to see whether men
are also over represented among homeless
among suicides among the unemployed you
long you know so and let's see actually
the last one's a little more complicated
but the other ones are all solid
examples where we can see wait a second
it looks like men are actually on those
measures they're over represented among
those doing worst I'm going to guess
that if you did a guine genie
coefficient for men you would have much
higher inequality on pick whatever
outcome it is that you want lifespan
Health span happiness
mental IQ income body count all the rest
of it so body counts probably the main
exception because there are prostitutes
who just have enormous numbers of
Partners they they probably increase the
inequality for women right but all of
your other ones are I think very good
and by the way like just what I'm doing
is what I think everyone should be doing
on these issues which is not just going
and saying I have a philosophy and it
applies in all cases it's like let's
think about the individual facts of the
individual cases and maybe your theory
will work eight times out of 10 someone
who thinks the theory Works a thousand
times out of a thousand it's like yeah
that's doesn't sound like anything that
happens to any actual theory about human
behavior it's more like someone who's so
dogmatic and fanatical in their sense of
their own omn omniscience that all facts
get twisted to fit the theory why is it
the case in your opinion then that
feminism is still such a pervasive
cultural meme if your assessment of it
is correct which is that the lack of
fairness doesn't seem to be affecting
women in the way that it's
proposed right that is a great question
I mean your wording makes it sound sort
of like feminism is is on the decline
but it's still lingering whereas I'd say
it's probably at least near its alltime
peak in terms of what's going on here is
my story I think there's an actually
very general human tendency to care more
about female well-being and especially
female suffering I don't think that this
is unique to the modern world of Western
countries think that you can read almost
any anything written by human beings
from almost any period and you'll see
this Norm you can go and read ancient
books like the Bible and if you want to
show that someone's really bad you show
them murdering
women right same thing in mythology this
is just a general human attitude that
murdering men it's like well you know
maybe at it coming but murdering women
that is something something that it is
just a a deeply rooted feeling in human
nature that is especially horrible and
what I think has happened in the modern
world is that we start with these very
standard human feelings that I think are
indeed deeply rooted in human nature and
evolution and then it becomes a
philosophy and once you make something a
philosophy then you take an attitude
which can be balanced against other
attitudes or it just be hypocrisy and it
doesn't get that bad as as it gets
implemented but once BEC a philosophy
then there's a demand for consistency
and once there's a demand for
consistency then you start overruling
everything else that actually comes down
on the other side and also treating
doubt and questions as Sin and that is I
think what really explains the success
of feminism is that it
codifies human feelings that have always
been around but nevertheless have been
held inconsistently and hypocritically
before which my view is given that the
philosophy is wrong hypocrisy and
inconsistency is an improvement over
consistency and and single-minded
devotion yeah I it's an interesting
point I certainly agree based on all of
the data that I've seen plus just my
intuitive sense of myself people seem to
have an awful lot more sympathy for
women falling behind despite the fact
that men on average seem to be falling
further behind there's studies that have
been done people will donate way more if
they find out that it's an all women's
shelter than if it's an all Men's
Shelter new St women are wonderful
effect yes news stories that uh proclaim
the successes of women seem to be
treated more favorably than ones that
proclaim the successes of men there's
this gamma bias that Dr John Barry's
identified which you may be familiar
with I mean when are there ever stories
about successful men I mean unless it's
like a homeless guy getting a job but
it's very hard to even picture what
these what this these stories are I
can't remember two two things that I
think are interesting here first one
being I don't don't disagree that if you
were to find out that women had been
murdered throughout history you would
have gone oh my God like this is an
aberration whereas sort of male
mortality is just a byproduct of
existence that being said women being
sexually
assaulted by some Waring tribe you know
I I learned about um the cultural
history of um how relationships have
evolved from a sort of culturally
memetic standpoint and women have
basically been property they've been
property of their kin they've been
property of their family they've been
property of their husbands for a very
long time so I would agree that out on
the extremes for women there are it's
treated as an aberration but there's
certainly a lot of mistreatment which
has just been ah it's part it's a Weezy
it's a woozy it's a we where the new
tribe we're taking over the old one so
there's there's some uh again it's the
not 1,000 times out of a thousand thing
right I mean there I would point out
that the usual story is we first murder
all the men and then we slave the women
which is terrible but still it's like
well which one you which one would you
rather be yeah I'd rather be enslaved
than murdered probably who you're
enslaved by yes does that there is a
little bit of that although there's also
is there a suicide opportunity to in
case it turns out to be worse um
definitely my preference is enslave me
first and then I will be looking for my
way out if it turns out to be more
horrible than death itself yeah on the
you know on the question of the legal
treatment of women of course that a lot
of most of this is in the premodern
period where we just don't have a lot of
good data I mean there's the legal
Doctrine where I think that at least
often you are correct although even
there it's a little complicated things
like under Roman law father is just
legally entit to murder any of his
children regardless of their gender um
now once you hear that it's like well
but they weren't actually doing it like
yeah I think that's true I think it is
extremely unusual as Darwin would
predict for someone to murder their own
children even when it's totally legal
but then I think you do have to look at
well what's the fact of the matter is it
really true that in a society where
women were legally considered to be the
property of the father that he act that
fathers actually did often dispose of
their daughters as if they were sheep or
rather is it like they rather were they
normal human beings where whatever the
law says your daughter says I don't want
to marry him daddy and he's like oh well
I couldn't possibly say no to her she
was crying I think that again there are
human universals and while there're are
of course cruel people who will do
terrible things if the law allows it
much more common for the emotions that
we take for granted today to have always
existed and like whining the emotion of
of whining and complaining yeah I mean
you think that started
after the like because the law changed
okay yeah like like of course people
people have always been doing these
kinds of things and again just the way
that if you read the literature of of
earlier periods you'll see that it does
not seem like women are living in fear
of their fathers going and doing things
to them because yeah Evolution fathers
love their children children they love
their daughters they love their sons and
then on you know on top of this this is
ba very basic human feeling that women's
suffering is especially important um so
you know like my favorite example of
this that I mentioned was the Hillary
Clinton quote about how women are the
biggest losers in war because they lose
Fathers and Sons just like um um yeah
don't the Fathers and Sons lose more
because they're dead yeah well this uh
are you familiar with gamma bias have
you heard this before see maybe under so
mean is it like like not caring much
about the lowest status people or what
is it it's specifically men so uh Dr
John bar Center for male psychology came
up with this it's really interesting
Insight once you see it you can't unsee
it um if there is a story which is pro
female it will sex the person if it's
Pro male it will desex it if it's
anti-male it will sex the person if it's
anti- female it will desex it ah yes
very so you end up with a skew so for
instance so why is it called the
gamma I don't know you'd have to ask him
he's been on the show and I'm pretty
sure I did uh I feel like there's other
biases that come before it and this this
happens to be there because it's in
order I'm not sure anyway um yeah that
makes perfect sense so for instance uh
Sarah everard was this um young woman
walking through a park in the UK she was
killed by a male police officer
absolutely terrible right and and there
was um a lot of protests about women
don't feel safe in these streets it was
a flasho for for sort of sex relations
one week later a man drowned jumping
into the river temps to save a woman who
had gone in the story essentially wasn't
covered and when it was covered his sex
wasn't revealed it was uh Londoner jumps
in to save person from drowning or woman
from drowning or something like that so
you do get this skew but okay I
mean what would be in your opinion it
sounds like at least part of the problem
feminism has a branding problem right
that it's coming in with an awful lot of
baggage mimetically culturally what
given the fact that there are still
causes that women need to have support
for even in the modern world what would
be your proposal for a uh
sanitized new version of something that
could talk about women's
issues I mean honestly I think I would
say that step one is just to get the
facts and find out whether it's even
true that women are doing especially
badly and if that is the opposite is
true then it's like well seems like we
should be focused on men but you what is
it you can Pat your head and rub your
stomach at the same time there will be
certain areas in which we would want to
focus on men for instance uh I know that
you've got some views on circumcision I
think I align pretty much with your
views on that like that's a very
particular wing of male disadvantage
right um looking at is there a way that
we can get women to become mothers and
then get them back into the workforce
that's like a very specific element of
this so would you try and make
everything quite sort of disperate and
have okay we're going to have a
employment for mother's department and
we're going to have a we need to not
circumcise our children Department um I
mean that Pat your head and rub your
belly thing is uh quite striking because
it's uh of course a lot of people can't
do that um what I would say is
that there's always priorities and
anytime that you say that my issue is
super important you are implicitly
actually saying that the other issues
are at least I I should go and get some
of the attention that other issues are
get
usually you're a little hazy about what
issues you want to
deemphasize but yeah I do think that
there are actually good reasons once you
realize that a problem is not a big deal
not to go and emphasize it and not to go
and prioritize it uh you've probably
heard of effective altruism it's this
idea that philanthropy should be based
upon first of all how big is the problem
second of all how much can we do about
it and what's the actual payoff that we
get so I would say that would be the
general guide I mean I do think that you
know not focusing on gender is at least
a good presumption because it is the
kind of thing that promotes the two
negative emotions that I'm mourning my
daughter about in the essay which first
of all antipathy of just being angry at
a bunch of other people who really are
not even responsible or at least you
know most of them are not and then
self-pity of just feeling like a victim
so I so like you don't want to have a
philosophy that encourages antipathy or
self-pity human nature already naturally
does way too much of both of these it is
better to go and try to Free Yourself of
antipathy and self-pity than it is to
Foster them or create a whole philosophy
that justifies them honestly I think
that there are a number of major issues
that the view that there is a problem is
just false so like the gender pay Gap I
just think that it is false to say that
women are being mistreated by labor
markets so the best thing would be if
there is first of all a recognition of
this fact second of all an apology for
making a lot of false accusations and
then we just we're just done with it we
move on so labor markets are actually
very fair people are getting paid based
upon their performance if you have
different preferences the market lets
you satisfy those be grateful and stop
the complaining and if you say well I
personally am being mistreated like well
then that's you know mostly like like
life is not perfectly fair but it's not
an issue primarily of or even according
to the evidence like you know of being a
woman it's just that life's unfair right
so you would deal with that on a Case by
case basis yes and just say or and of
course if an individual says I'm being
treated unfairly my normal advice is hm
like is the person you're dealing with
at all open reason it's like well no if
they were we already talked about like
well you probably need to get away for
that person right or unless there's some
other more you know person above that
person that's open to reason but I mean
this is just like practical guidance for
living life you can't expect that other
people are going to be fair to you
overall and you need to be on the one
hand looking out for yourself but also
not creating a big story about how life
is not fair to you or to your kind when
the evidence doesn't back that up what
do you think are the tradeoffs that
feminism is making at the moment because
what is it it seems to me like women
aren't necessarily benefiting from
feminism in the way that they might
think but are they being hurt by it h
that's a good question I mean and in a
way it it's sort of reinforces my point
that we especially care about women
suffering the arguments against feminism
that the most acceptable are the on
where we say it's actually hurting women
right those are the ones like oh my God
that's terrible the most Pro the most
Pro feminist argument is the
anti-feminist argument yes um in terms
of what's going on so I I I think for at
the individual level the main issue is
just promoting negative attitudes of
antipathy and
self-pity what I tell my daughter is
like it is just not true that men in
general are out to get you or won't like
you you know my advice is if you want to
do well in the world go and make make
make as many friends as you can
especially friends with people that are
in position to go and help you and the
way that you make friends is by being
friendly to them and being and not
having and and having a positive and
constructive attitude so and I say like
antipathy gets in the way of that
antipathy just makes your default oh
this person is going to treat me badly
this person is going to be unreasonable
or unfair so there's that and then same
thing with the self-pity like like you
know self-pity is really baked into
human nature like you never need to
encourage it there's just so much Sal
poor me I don't have the latest iPhone
it's totally human nature to feel that
way so like really what you need to
focus on is everything you've got all
your opportunities be grateful for what
you have and this is the attitude of a
of a person that is going to be
successful so those are the main issues
in terms of the individual woman i' say
that there's this other big effect of
just mistreating men right which again
is not like said wait well mistreating
men well who cares about them like
that's the attitude that I I'm saying is
a terrible attitude it's bad to be
unjust a man you you should not be
unjust to anyone the fact that they're
men doesn't mean that it's okay and that
whatever happens to them too bad like
this is payback for 2,000 years of them
mistreating us I like well was that true
either so there's that in you know you
know in ter in terms of sort of like
Collective harmm you know there's there
is a lot of work on things like
discrimination law saying that if people
are worried you're going to sue them
this is a reason for them to not hire in
the first place I think that there's
definitely something going on there and
it's something to consider in terms of
whether sex discrimination law in
general benefits women though on balance
it still might but you know it's a
benefit that is based upon a deep
Injustice wow okay yeah so uh the
widespread litigious nature of women
especially being super vigilant for
potential um mistreatment in the
workplace
could cause some employers to look at a
woman and think she looks like she's got
a good solicitor let's not hire her in
case something occurs down the line yeah
I mean I I know uh oh yeah I mean so
probably one of the best examples where
I think it is true that women were hurt
by me too specifically is there is a
couple papers showing that mentorship
crashed after me too yep I've seen these
and that is obviously beneficial to
women to go and get extra training from
someone but uh strikingly the main
feminist response to this was we will
not tolerate this reaction we will we we
will it is totally ridiculous to go and
penalize us because of this irrational
fear that you might get sued and we're
we just need to go and tell men that
this is not acceptable and yeah well
this is a situation where they're going
to totally agree and then probably keep
doing what is not hire you in any case
for them or not meant you know hiring is
it's one where it's formal and so it's
easier to litigate but mentorship is
informal and anything informal is very
hard to litigate unless you're going to
have a system that just convicts people
on an accusation which I think is a lot
of what feminists want to do so what
what what I'm feeling here is on on
average of course there is I I emphasize
everything is on average that's fine the
entire podcast is on average dot dot dot
excellent um what I'm feeling here is an
echo I'm I'm sensing the equivalency on
the male side of the Spectrum which I'm
sure that you've seen movement like the
black pill movement um incel ideology
stuff like that I have a number of
friends that are very deep into the
research with this uh and I do think
that there's way less misogyny in these
groups than you might think the actual
most misogynistic men are the ultra high
performing Chads not the ones that are
the uh sort of uh forgotten Monster
Energy marinated incels but there is an
awful lot of self-pity there is an awful
lot of antipathy within the these groups
toward the opposite sex so this isn't
necessarily uh a feminist Quirk this is
a natural human response that can then
be kind of perpetuated and spun up once
you get into a group that has an
outre yes absolutely so I have been
actually doing compare and contrast
reading incel the incel wiki and then I
think the fem geek Wiki there's a lot of
similarity between them I mean I've
noticed that in arguing with feminists
they often say Brian you're just
repeating incel talking points I'm like
no um I am I am saying some things that
they say that are true while not
actually adopting the whole philosophy
which I agree is a very destructive one
of antipathy and self bitty what I would
say is that the incels that you so
despise they really are the mirim of you
and I think of myself as being someone
who's just trying to fairly arbitrate
between two unreasonable groups um it
and you know and you know course to go
and say that women you know on you know
on balance are not treated less fairly
than men does not mean that there aren't
any specific female complaints that are
true of course there are um but also
there are some specific male complaints
that are true and and then like course
like the more you read them the more you
realize well look people just need to
tolerate some level of unfairness in
society because otherwise people will
barely be able to breathe it's like yeah
and that goes both ways do you remember
uh Scott Aronson's description of his
experience probably what 15 years old
now maybe 10 years old something like
that that blog post could you explain
for the people who aren't familiar with
this and then Scott Alexander's Untitled
uh blog post after that could you give I
think this really instructive yeah um
for the record so I'm good friends with
Scott arenson I've hung out with the mot
in Texas uh but I also have read the
pieces so I I will claim to have some
inside knowledge of the situation
although filtered through his
perspective but I trust scottt I trust
both Scotts but I especially Trust Scott
arenson who I know well personally
so Scott Aronson did a piece for his
blog Shadle optimized where he and this
is barely even a caricature of it he
said look I'm I 98% agree with feminism
like like I'm so on board I care so much
but I just want to say one thing which
is that when I was a teenager I was
almost suicidal or really I was suicidal
because I read a lot of feminist
writings when I just felt like any
thought I had about women was wrong any
attempt to go and talk to them any
attempt to go and just have some
desperate hope eort hopeless effort to
go and find a girlfriend was wrong
thought that anything that I might do or
say would be harassment and you know
eventually I learn better but anyway
it'd be nice if in the midst
of fighting actual Injustice against
women you could just go and show A
Little Bit of Sympathy a little little
bit of understanding for shy male neres
like myself especially when they're
young and they just don't have much
experience and they don't understand
what's going on on and then the feminist
reaction to this was generally
hysterical calling him a rapist or an
incipient rapist entitled yes yes
entitled like you know you think that
you have a right to sex and it's like he
didn't say any of those things you
rather what he said is you know I pledge
98% you 98% of what you say is true and
I just have a few slight doubts and you
just be a little bit nicer the that's it
and for that like like the reaction was
so just absurd and insane and it is it
is the one where you just look at that
and you say like like you know this is a
cult of Fanatics he's talking about I
did get a chance actually to tell Scott
like did that really make you rethink
that whole 98% thing I'm not gonna
repeat Scott's answer but I definitely
did hassle him about that say how about
we go down more to like 5% from 98 could
we do that look so his here's the thing
that I think is uh the the inevitable
ping pong game that occurs happening and
I saw this with Melissa Carie who came
on the podcast recently she wrote a book
called uh the two parent privilege uh
how America stopped getting married and
started falling behind something like
that she is a policy wonk from
Washington DC and I tried in the episode
to uh push her Beyond just what is the
data telling us to what is the
implication and maybe even what is the
cause of this like what's the give me
the mechanism why is it the case what is
happening developmentally amongst the
children and she was very tentative
right you know she's written this big
book about things but she very much kind
of defined the rules of play of where
where she wasn't going to get out over
her skis with regards to this and I was
like that's like a I I wish that she'd
just bro signs to we through stuff
because it's funny but what she did was
she decided I'm going to hold myself
within this sort of uh within my realm
of expertise and I was like that's a
pretty good indication of somebody
that's acting in good faith with a lot
of like and trying to be really really
accurate with what they say since she's
released it she has been slammed online
absolutely slammed and what I've seen
although I don't think that this is
going to happen to her I've seen
somebody who is probably on a political
COMPASS test center left certainly
somebody who wrote a book to try and
reduce inequality between Class groups
right this is exactly exacerbating the
precise inequality that we don't want to
have happen and so on and so forth and
it was written as far as I can see with
a good amount of compassion but I'm
seeing the exact mechanism by which many
people become radical ized to one side
or another side of some sort of a
because they think well I mean if I
guess the only people that are ever
going to listen to me about the woes
that I have about the Justified or
sometimes unjustified antipathy or
self-pity that I've got well I like I'm
going to go with the group that accept
me accepts me I'm not going to keep on
you know trying to work here's 98% of my
entire world going toward you group that
says that you despise me and I'm an
entitled [__] Insel or something like
that rap
rapist rapist for like a rapist in his
heart is like straight out of the New
Testament original sin so yeah just my
point being that you know I see here um
especially the antipathy it creates this
ever escalating cycle right that spins
up and up and up and people become uh
more virulent in their distaste and
their uh lack of ability to see the
other side's issue and this is how you
have you know two groups of people
largely just talking past each other mhm
yeah I mean think about what Scott
Alexander calls the gray tribe and this
is the which he admits it's still a
tribe but it's a tribe with different
norms and better Norms that's trying to
not actually fall into being either of
the other either the blue tribe or the
red tribe as we call them confusingly
here in the US um so every other country
in the world red equals left but somehow
in the US red equals right got the wrong
way around yes uh and then blue I don't
know what side of the road that you
drive on you got it the wrong way around
yes but
where I think like we're at least the
only country that has this color scheme
but yeah yeah uh but anyway um yeah so
that's makes quite a lot of sense I me
think we're mentioning then you know the
Scott arenson reaction to this was just
to write a piece defend or excuse me the
Scott Alexander reaction was to write a
piece standing up for Scott Aronson and
saying yes like there is this group of
shy male nerds who want to talk to women
they're not very good at it doesn't mean
that they have any horrible anything any
horrible plans like they're very usually
very nice people it's just that they
don't really know how to talk to women
and the only way to learn is to try it
and not be very good at it at first so
can't you go and cut them some slack I
think is totally reasonable point you
had an idea about why we all get accused
of being pickpockets what was
that right this was specifically a
reference to the humiliation of
mandatory training that happens here at
universities a lot um so so you like
imagine if there was some kind of
mandatory pickpocket training where they
bring in all the workers and they say
pickpocketing is wrong don't pickpocket
others pickpocketing others means
reaching into their pockets without
permission and taking their stuff and
then keeping it don't be a pickpocket
all right and it's like okay um why are
you telling me this though like I know
all this already this is all quite
obvious and and yet to me this is very
much what most sensitivity train is like
what most of the training about you know
like Internet Security is like they're
telling you a bunch of totally obvious
stuff and again why well a lot of it is
really just seems to be to humiliate you
to say look we we are going to talk to
you like children and you have to sit
there and suck it up tough luuck some of
it is for legal purposes where if they
get sued they can say we told them not
to do it right as if the main reason
people pickpocket is they don't they no
one ever told them not to do it or they
don't understand what would constitute
it although another part of it is
ratcheting up the definition so that
almost anything counts as pickpocketing
where it's like well you looked at what
was in someone's pocket without their
consent that's a kind of pickpocketing
so I think that's also what's going on
and once you have your training set up
they do often start having higher and
higher standards now I say this just to
go and make fun of various training that
you'll see especially on college
campuses about sexual rment it's like
don't sleep with their students oh I
didn't know we weren't supposed to do
that oh thank you like come on like we
all know this right you know the reason
why people are doing it isn't because
they aren't aware of the rules the
reason they're doing it is because they
don't like the rules and the rules are
stopping them from doing what they want
so again if it really an issue of
something that's really confusing be a
different story so maybe actually the
Internet Security at least you might
think that that's more complicated
although honestly having gone through
internet security training I'll say that
the stuff they train you on is so basic
because honestly they need to make a
test that can be passed by the lowest IQ
person in the
organization and therefore they can't
really be hard because otherwise they'd
have to fire people over failing their
it test it training over over they don't
want to do that so one of the things
that we're both fans of is uh agency
trying to give people a sense of
personal agency individual sovereignty
it seems to me and I hadn't thought of
these two words before but it seems like
antipathy and pity are yeah self-pity
the pity for others antipathy and
self-pity are probably about as close to
solvents for agency as possible like it
will dissolve your ability to feel like
a an agentic individual oh yeah that's a
great point I mean yeah because like
what I like to tell people is imagine a
person who has the absolute maximum
reason to feel antipathy and
self-pity like someone who was stabbed
in the back and now they're paralyzed
and they know the person who did it you
know like I don't know it was like your
your ex-wife stabbed you in the back now
you're paralyzed from the neck down for
the rest of your life so you have every
reason to hate this person every reason
to feel sorry for yourself and the
question is if you wanted to help this
person would you go to them and say be
full of antipathy be full of self-pity
like of course not You' be trying to go
and come up with some story to make them
feel better and it's like well okay I
like I understand why you would be
overwhelmed with antipathy and self-pity
but you got to get past that because if
you're going to have any enjoyment out
of life if you're going to be able to
salvage any part of what you're hoping
for you're G to have to go and focus on
what you can do and what you can have
now and just being angry at the at the
woman who did this to you and feeling
sorry for for poor you though completely
Justified is totally
unconstructive what would you say then
given that we have an incredibly broad
number of people who are wallowing in a
low agency existence
what's your prescription uh
philosophically or tactically or
strategically for getting someone from
antipathy and self-pity into
agency the movie What About Bob actually
the lead psychologist in it has a book
called Baby Steps about how someone who
has problems needs to give up on the
idea of solving them all overnight and
instead just try to take small little
steps of improvement um you know the
character is mock worthy in the movie
but I think it's totally sensible if a
person is having trouble with life don't
say fix everything overnight just say
all right look let's take some small
steps and move from there so that's what
I would be in by doing I mean in terms
of philosophy I'd say that
philosophically it's easier to go and
just realize a philosophy is wrong than
to get rid of all the negative
negativity that the philosophy has
inspired you you know just the very fact
that you decide the philosophy is
incorrect doesn't mean you won't you'll
stop feeling bad about the things the
philosophy taught you to feel bad about
uh but still I would I would say all
right well just you know next time that
you are feeling bad about this remember
like there's a philosophy that
originally got me feeling bad about this
the philosophy is wrong so now try to go
and rethink the situation from a
different point of view I would say that
as well I mean also I honestly I would
just say don't hang out like another
good baby step is hang out more with
people who who do not feel so much
antipathy and self-pity so that your new
your group is encouraging you to improve
instead of holding you back yeah I think
uh the story that you tell yourself
about why you're feeling bad and what
does it mean that I feel bad and what is
the story that I tell myself about that
this kind of recursive uh narrative game
that you play with yourself probably
counts for a big chunk of the discontent
and the pain that you feel right yeah
you have the situation but then you have
these layers of guilt and shame and
doubt and self-esteem or lack thereof
that you layer on top and I think that
is where the uh philosophical worldview
comes in quite importantly like is this
happening to me did I get to choose this
you know there's a a study which I'm
sure you've seen about two rats are in
uh Wheels one rat runs and when it runs
the other rat has to run the one rat
that runs gets all of the benefits from
exercise and the rat that has to run
gets all of the downsides from stress
the point being that know being able to
take your sense of control your locus of
control being internal is a very very
large part of of life and uh mean what's
interesting about that to me is that I
actually have a moderate Locust control
because I just think it's true that luck
is important in
life I you know so I realized that it
would probably be psychologically better
for me to have the false belief that
there's no luck but I just think that's
such an insane view that I'm not going
to so blind myself to the fact well you
kind of got lucky making this friend at
that right that time and it's youed by
your own rationality yeah yeah so but
you know like it's also like you just be
really positive about the things that
you can change focus on those you don't
need to tell yourself a big lie in order
to motivate yourself to say look there's
a lot of stuff that's in my power and
I'm gonna do that stuff this do remind
me of one of my favorite movies uh I
hope this isn't giving away giving away
in spoilers but it's so obscure that I
just doubt that anyone would watch it
anyway but it's called The Upside of
Anger and the basic plot and I you ever
seen have you seen it by any chance no
uh the basic plot is that there is a dad
of you know there's a family there's a
mom a dad and I think there four
daughters and the dad runs off of the
secretary and just disappears and
abandons the entire family and the mom
becomes a terrible raging alcoholic and
she just hates the world she's so mad
and then there's the interaction between
her and the daughters and on and on and
then at the end of the movie they
discover that it is not true the father
ran away or abandoned them the father
just fell into a ditch and died and and
he had and nothing to do with the
secretary or anything else and then you
just realize wow you learn a fact and
then you suddenly realize all this these
this anger that I had is just wrong just
predicated on a totally false story of
the world and in watching the movie you
can almost instantly see people saying
like I don't feel angry anymore because
my anger was based upon a story that is
false now I don't think that just
abandoning a whole philosophy of life is
going to make it quite as easy to feel
good as that one very particular sense
of betrayal but you like really in the
story it's very psychologically credible
that the anger just gets replaced with a
sense of horrible guilt that how could I
have so wrongly judged this person who
actually was loyal to his family the
whole time and had an accident
so I swear this makes sense in my mind
let's see if it makes sense in public I
went to dinner with uh RFK Jr about 3
months ago when he was in Austin was a
bunch of there was a bunch of different
people there lots of interesting people
uh one of them was Tim Kennedy who's a
Green Beret you might know he lives in
Austin he does a a sort of um
selfdefense thing called Sheep dog
response Tim Kennedy was open carrying
as he does because that's that's he's an
ex you say did you say Tim Kennedy yes
so so wait is he is he also a
Kennedy uh actually different different
Kennedy I was getting confused by the
story UFC fighter Green Beret but but
unrelated to the Kennedy family
precisely correct all of RFK Jr's
security was outside he had some staff
in with him but it was a lady PR person
and maybe an assistant of some kind and
some other stuff he had no security
inside tons outside right but no
security inside and I would remember
looking at the gun on uh Tim's hip and
thinking if he pulled that gun out now
and shot RFK Jr in the head his entire
career would be gone back over with a
tooth comb to work out exactly the
moment when he became a Russian Sleeper
Agent oh it was that UFC fight that they
did in Abu Dhabi when secretly the Saudi
Prince met him backstage and that was
when they changed him and the every
podcast he's ever done would be
reanalyzed bit by bit he did this series
called finding Hitler searching for
Hitler or whatever oh the the reason he
did that was to get into Argentina
because that's where they've got and
what I realized was like individual
actions can cause retroactively for the
entire story to be rechanged and it's
almost like the same as what you're
talking about right that his entire life
would have been looked at in a different
manner so yeah I totally see how that's
the case one of the things I guess to
just round out this sort of agency part
that I think would be interesting to
find out from you is if somebody is or
somebody has a friend that is struggling
with the self-pity and the antipathy and
the externalized locus of control overly
externalized locus of control what have
you found anything that is a good Salve
for that that can kind of start to give
people a little bit of perspective look
you can enact change in your life there
are things that you can do this isn't
just happening to you is there anything
philosophically that you find yourself
relying on if you end up getting too
close to antipathy and
self-pity I think much more often about
how to make people feel happier with
their lives and how to raise their locus
of control um I so normally what I tell
them is look the most important cause of
human happiness or unhappiness is
whether you're spending a lot of time
with people's company you enjoy um now
that itself comes down to locus of
control like well I I am with I am stuck
with people whose company I don't enjoy
and I say well like you're not really
stuck with them like you may say you're
stuck with them but you could go and try
you know like you know like go through
your mental Ro deck of people who
already know aren't there some people
that you like more that you don't spend
much time with and could you try to
spend more time with them some people
that you like less and you could just
turn down the dial a bit you don't need
to start purging your grandma because
she has a big mouth you could just see
her half as often so but I would think
of that as actually itself you T
definitely touching on Locust of control
because you are telling them to go and
take you know take actions in order to
go and make and make themselves happier
so I guess I would probably start there
in terms of just saying look you know
focus on things that you can do that
will improve your life and things that
you can do don't focus on what you can't
do I think that's all totally reasonable
I mean I recently did two really popular
posts one on advice for men on finding
their soulmate and the other one on
advice for women on finding their
soulmate I think if you go through a lot
of it is basically saying like you know
exert more Locust of control right so
like you know like there's a lot of
things you can do and these are some of
the easiest steps you can take in order
to make what you want to happen happen
but yeah if you just sit there saying
like poor me then yeah nothing's gonna
happen of course you know at least
almost certainly you you could just wait
to be saved someone says oh I'm Gonna
Save You what were the important
differences between men finding their
soulmate and women finding their
soulmate let's see good one I think for
both groups I said put less weight on
physical attractiveness although I think
for men I said it's especially important
for them to put less weight on that and
I said look just consider this thought
experiment imagine you're married to a
super model but she has a terrible
personality how do you feel about your
life like everyone say yeah terrible I
mean I even said imagine you start
dating a supermodel but she has a
terrible personality how long does it
take before you are miserable and yeah
like three weeks so all right well I
think you already agree with my point
it's just a matter of exerting the
self-control to focus on personality
overlooks which I think you know both
genders do it but it's especially bad
for men
C4 U and for both genders I was telling
them things like you figure out these
top priorities and then just downweight
everything else be flexible and
everything else for women I did have
this advice of just go older so like
like just go five 10 years older
especially because a very common
complaint for women is men my age are so
immature all right well they don't have
to be your age they could be five years
older and you know you could go and find
an immature guy and then hope to change
him and he'll turn out and become a
mature guy but a lot of guys never
become mature if you get an older guy
you can say well is he mature already no
in that case no and if he is great I
don't have to speculate about his future
maturity because it's he's already there
you know someone says look I can't
possibly do that it's too gross it's
like well what's the most you're willing
to do
yeah that's cool yeah I I see an awful
lot of the an awful lot of the
complaints from uh women who are
struggling to find men that they think
is sufficiently mature at their age and
you see this in it it seems to be tied
up in the data that there is a
significantly bigger portion of 18 to 30
men who are single than 18 to 30 women
who are single so I think women have
already largely cottoned onto this again
it fixes the tall girl problem of women
out earning men socioeconomically
because age is one of the biggest is
predicted of wealth and if wealth is
something that you need to offset all
right we'll just give him a seven-year
Head Start and there he is he's out
ahead of you yeah I mean I think like
another big difference I said well so
for men I said look you just have to get
get over your lack of confidence and ask
right so that's important but but for
women what I said is look it's true that
you don't have to ask in order to get
dates but you you do need to ask to get
the guy you want probably I said like
you know for women just to get a little
bit more flexible on being willing to go
and ask
and I think for them I said look if you
just feel Tongue Tied like especially
for a woman just telling a guy you seem
promising like oh my God like I hate you
now like you told me I seem promising
like like it's it's on the one hand like
it is far from throwing yourself at a
guy but same time I it is unambiguous I
think I also mentioned like you know the
sense of It's Always obvious what the
other person wants so there's no need
for me to tell them or it's always
obvious what I want rather it's no need
to tell them like just forget that
nonsense people are not mind readers we
have like we so greatly overrate other
people's ability to read us because
we're always thinking what we're
thinking but we never get inside anyone
else's head and and the idea that
everyone secretly knows what it is
you're thinking and they're just playing
Dam especially if you're talking about
the opposite sex especially if you're
talking about the opposite sex we have
no idea how the inside of your mind
works yeah I uh I had a a pie we got
some idea
but I had a piece advice I was throwing
around for a while about receptivity
from women so a lot of women still have
they feel like there's an additional
lowering in status if they make the
first move but there's this story you'll
have heard of dropping a handkerchief
that the ladies would have done in the
sort of Renaissance period and the
aristocracy would drop a handkerchief
the gentleman would pick it up and that
would be the beginning of the
conversation like the modern equivalent
of that is a gaze that lingers a little
bit too long also women need to kind of
adjust the sights of whatever they're
shooting with to account for me too and
concern that going to make a woman feel
uncomfortable so there's an awful lot of
sort of moving moving moving Parts here
one of the other things that I quite
enjoy before you move on so one of my
big piece of advice to my daughter is
never be afraid to play the I'm not one
of those feminist cards with men oh yes
okay so yeah and again this is one where
of course I knew a lot of people would
get get angry about it but I said look
I'm not saying to go and denounce women
or other I'm saying look just put people
at ease if someone is nervous it is
common sense and strategically wise just
to go and smile and just say it's all
cool don't worry I'm a decent person I
don't prejudge you as being bad and I
think that the I'm not one of those
feminist cards is one of the best ones
for women to play it really does
distinguish you from women that men just
feel like they have to walk on eggshells
around to one where they will talk to
you freely right it's great for work
great for dating great for for actually
making friends
know the only thing that's holding
people back is loyalty to this
philosophical
Dogma why do you think there's been a
demonization of having children over the
last few years it feels like this is
kind of tied into a lot of feminist meta
memes uh and meta cultures that's going
on we've seen a decline in fertility
rates what what do you think's going on
with this demonization of specifically
having kids I think that the
demonization comes from a very narrow
corner of mostly the internet the real
story is not so much demonization as
just apathy and disinterest uh it is
true there is a demonization corner uh
my younger son reads reddits all the
time and he's saying okay dad like right
the child-free people they're not that
bad but the anti-natalist they're crazy
the Indi naal the people who post videos
of kids getting trampled by horses and
stuff like that and like what right but
I am familiar with philosophical
anti-natalism I mean really does seem to
heavily flow from the work of South
African philosopher David benitar U and
he came up with this argument that to my
mind is truly bizarre you know like he
has a number of arguments but the
hardcore argument comes down to No One
cons sense to be born because they can't
because they don't exist yet and any
everyone who exists will experience some
suffering and even if that suffering is
overwhelmingly out outweighed by by Joy
still it is wrong to ever inflict
suffering on anyone without their
consent and therefore it's always wrong
to have kids right and this argument has
persuaded a strangely large number of
people to my mind and you know my reply
to this is so this implies the Good
Samaritan is evil because you can't like
how do you know that unconscious guy
doesn't want to die you're going and
administering first aid to a man who was
beaten into senselessness but how do you
know that he doesn't want to just bleed
out it's like well there is this
philosophical Doctrine called hypothe
itical consent which normally is bogus
because we can just ask you whether you
consent but it is custom made for cases
where like well he would probably
consent if he was conscious but he can't
similar you would probably consent to be
born or to be conceived if you could but
you can't but it's reasonable to presume
it uh then there is a broader category
of people just think that life isn't
worth living epicurus answered this
2,500 years ago and his his reply just
consisted in well we're in Greece
there's cliffs don't like it jump
off I have gotten you I I I got a
threatening email from my University's
mental health office for promoting
suicide for saying stuff like this it's
like look I'm not do you even understand
what he University is about it's about
thinking about things it's not like if
that counts as promoting suicide to say
epicurus said something and it and it's
a good argument I don't know what you're
doing on a University campus but I I I
I'm familiar with benar one of my
friends has podcasted with him albeit
when he didn't have his screen on
because he's still pseudonymous or
largely Anonymous or whatever really but
but he's known as a philosopher so but
no one knows his face I don't think well
he teaches at a university how can they
know his face I don't know if he teaches
under his real name I don't know whether
that's a pseudonym I might be wrong
anyway okay well anyway so check it for
the show notes even if we even if we
step ourselves a little bit away from
the hardcore anti-natalist philos phers
again you could maybe call it a
generalized anti-child culture right and
this is more toward the ambiguity uh
that you mentioned about having kids
this hyper
individualism uh where do you think that
comes from h i mean I think feminism
definitely has something to do with it
especially the idea that any woman that
thinks that raising kids should be your
first priority as an adult is just
stupid and foolish and is sort of being
a doormat to the patriarchy um I mean is
striking to me
that if there were a girl today in
especially Suburban High School who said
I just want to be a mom I think that the
like the outcry against that would be
overwhelming not because they hate the
idea of having kids but because they
elevate the idea of having a career as
being the most important thing in life
and kid as being an optional thing and I
would think these are two both two
extremely important things in life and
yeah this is there's a trade-off of
course right as a homeschooling dad who
actually did all the night shift for all
four my kids I can say yeah I probably
would have one or two more books if I
had no kids but I chose to be less
successful as a professor so that I
could go and have kids because that was
more important to me and still is oh so
there's a big uh there's a big mimetic
element going on here with regards to
Children ah so you know I mean I that's
totally true I think that is a separate
point but yes to a large degree well so
I mean at least mically in in terms of
imitating other people there's a
conformist element El just the fact that
we have baby booms and bus a lot of it
seems to be that child you like you know
the number of children that you want to
have is based fairly heavily upon just
what's normal in your culture or
subculture so that's uh you you know one
major factor going on which means you
can sort of get a multiplied you can get
a multiplied effect where if women there
say women are focusing more on their
careers that has a direct effect
reducing fertility but it also has the
indirect effect of it's now normal to
have fewer kids which then means that
even people not focused in their careers
want to go and fit in uh I have worked
quite a bit with the actual data of
fertility and especially desire you know
I think both uh accomplished and desired
fertility and what's so like two big
lessons that I like to trumpet so one is
at least on American data it is that it
is not true that income by itself leads
to lower fertility in fact income by
itself leads to higher fertility really
what's going on is that education leads
to lower fertility and so and if you
rise education against income you see
that that education reduces fertility
and income increases it and the basic
upshot of this is that the most fertile
people are high income low education
groups like say plumbers and on the
other hand the least fertile groups are
high education lowincome like say
philosophers who drive a taxi all right
so that's and once you put it this way
you realize H so it isn't really the
material element it's more of the social
element of Education if we actually were
teaching kids in school things like
babies are D babies are gross babies are
terrible David benitar has the right
argument I don't know of any school that
really does that it's more of you just
teach people other priorities as being
of overwhelming importance and then just
like with problems if you talk about one
problem all the time you are implicitly
saying other problems don't matter and
if you talk about only one life goal as
being important all the time you're
implicitly saying other life goals don't
matter
uh the other result that I think
is very well let's see it's not
surprising but it's really weth saying
because it's the kind of thing people
wouldn't want to say without data but I
do have the
data it's that women's education and
women's income are much more important
for determining the outcomes than the
men's education income for both genders
it's got the same direction but
basically looks very much like women's
preferences are a lot more important for
the
outcome which comes down to
something like women have an actual
definite opinion about how many kids
they want to have men are more along for
the ride and like oh you want to have
three kids great want to have one kid
great uh it's not quite that men don't
have any preference at all and don't
bargain or don't select but it really is
more of the of the kind of decision that
women uh women dominate in within the
family is how many kids are we going to
have right so right so say in terms of
getting f up you got to change women's
Minds that's more important generally a
high income man married to a medium low
education
woman uh might be able to get this
moving a little bit oh yeah I mean you
by the way I also in my advice for men
and women I say like you know find out
how many kids they want early maybe not
the first date but say by the third date
like it's important thing to know yeah
yeah the uh social desirability bias is
something that I learned from you that
you said is the most underrated effect
in all of psychology and I I kind of
can't stop seeing it now good explain it
to people that aren't familiar simple
idea when the truth sounds bad people
lie and often the truth if the truth is
said sufficiently and frequently people
stop even being conscious about lying I
mean really mundane examples are things
like am fat there's only one acceptable
answer to that oh Brian you look great
you're wonderful you're beautiful just
the way you are um we can see this in
lots of different areas you can see it
in things like church attendance more
people claim they went to church than
actually went to church more people
claim to vote than actually vote U one
of my favorite examples of all is
there's actually a study of first of
all you ask people would you abort a
Down syndrome fetus and only about I
think like 20 25% of people say they
would say they would but then we see
what what happens when people are
actually in that situation and then it's
more like
90% all right now again this doesn't
necessarily mean that people were truly
lying but they were just blurting out
what sounded good without thinking about
it until they needed to actually make a
decision and then suddenly it's no
longer just words I've go oh my God like
I don't want to do that stated and
revealed preferences are a hell of a
drug oh yes that's quite right now I
have a lot of applications of this some
again as mundane as the the strange
language of want to come to my party on
Saturday oh I can't it's like hm well
will you be in a cage will you be in the
middle of
Siberia unable to get to a plane in time
what do you mean you can't and the
answer is right fine I don't want to is
the truth I say I can't in know because
that sounds better even though it is um
actually literally correct I won't yes I
won't I when you come to my body I won't
I won't yes I won't why why not because
I don't because I have so there are
things to do that would be better than
that for me like what is that like
sitting home watching TV that's better
yeah often the answer uh but then I say
there are many areas of life where
social desability bias just becomes so
overwhelmingly it's almost the only
thing going on so I encourage people
just to go and first of all read any
political speech by politician they
don't like and just go through the
sentences one by one and say like could
this possibly be literally true and I
think you'll find wow like the
politicians I don't like are lying all
the time when pfac goes and says Trump
lies like 70% of the time like no 99.9%
is the correct number because you just
read the sentence and it'll be sentences
it'll be things like we're doing
everything possible for this no you
aren't if you're doing everything
possible there you spend zero on
anything else right so no wrong false
and obviously so therefore a lie is that
not uh part of just the imprecision of
language and the fact that when we speak
there is a degree of uh like Whimsy that
kind of comes along for the ride
interesting question yeah many people
say all right well everybody knows it's
not meant to be literally true
I say actually it's the kind of thing
where I think politicians are playing on
the ambiguity of maybe it's literally
true maybe it's not if they say this is
an existential risk that's Putin's story
about why they have to invade Ukraine
it's an is existential risk comad all
right and it's like now like when people
hear this is everyone is all the
supporters saying well obviously it's
not really existential but like he's
saying that to get people's attention or
there are a whole lot of people who are
actually believing it just like it's the
truth from God's mouth and I think
actually in politics there's a lot of
people who are just taking it very
naively and and so I do think it is a
problem I think that it's not merely
that you have to double the rhetoric to
get the same result that you would have
gotten if everyone spoke honestly I
think rather there are just a lot of
things that government does that if
people were honest just wouldn't
exist like like if people and during Co
were to say look I'll you uh ra rather
than saying look we're doing this to
keep people safe
they'd said we're doing this in order to
reduce the number of fatalities from 1
million to 950,000 I think there' just
be a lot less support for the measures
if you if you were that honest about it
it well that fundamentally comes down to
is it useful or is it true right there
are things that you can say that are
useful the things that are true that
become less useful and you go okay well
what's the point of this communication
is it to communicate the truth or is it
to get the intended outcome yes although
as soon as someone starts doing that
then it's like wait useful for who
useful for you to get power and hold it
hm I wonder if that's something
politicians care about as opposed to
getting the best overall result for
society doing careful cost benefit
analysis after collecting the best
possible statistics we could find even
that though all the way down still ends
up with lexical semantic [__] and you
know just it's trademark yeah precisely
it's lexical semantic [__] you heard
it here first um because what people
then start to do is they make lies of
omish and than lies of Commish and they
purposefully obfuscate not using words
that allow them to be held up it's what
happens in Law Courts it's so on and so
forth well I didn't say you can't prove
that it's necessarily not the case that
precisely precisely yeah yeah it just it
just becomes a game of of plausible
deniability so I I think this is kind of
the equivalent of the justification for
performance-enhancing drugs legitimized
Olympics I think just let let the gloves
come off and lie as much as you want
don't ever hold anybody to any account
and just let it become a neural
linguistic programming soup and just see
who can make the best lies all the way
down and let's see who wins
then yeah I I I I confess to some slight
like emotional sympathy but I think that
you if you just look at the world and to
see like you know the very worst
governments in the world are the have
the biggest lying demagogues um part of
this I'll say is because whe these are
almost always dictators and the dictator
can just get away with bigger lies yeah
yeah yeah you so like you know there
there are just so many applications of
social desirability bias one of my
favorites actually is understanding what
is the point of propaganda I'm a huge
Orwell fan and if you read Orwell it
sounds like the whole point of
propaganda is just to tell like is is is
basically to obscure the actual the
actual truth and or basically to crush
the truth or excuse me not propaganda
censorship rather censorship so so you
read Orwell it sounds like the whole
point of censorship is that the
government wants to crush the truth
because they know that in the contest
between the truth and a lie the LIE will
be defeated so they have to go and
imprison anyone anyone who speaks the
truth nice story but here's the thing if
you go and look at dictatorships say
that they spend a lot more time crushing
other lies than they do crushing the
truth let you go to Saudi Arabia they're
not that worried about the atheist
saying like how do we know that the
Quran is even true they're much more
worried about amula saying Allah does
not ordain the house of sad Allah
ordains me those are the people that put
fear into the hearts of a middle eastern
islamist Tyrant because that person is
saying a competing lie so the title of
this essay is you monopolize the Pretty
Lies point of censorship is say only I
get to tell ridiculous lies anyone who
says any other lies I will kill you I
certainly think I remember Rob Henderson
writing something about the goal of
propaganda is not to control what you
think it's to convince you of what other
people think so it's basically a game of
of you will through the abalene Paradox
and through mimetic desire and through
social desirability bias and so on you
will end up doing what you think other
people think so the goal is not actually
to change your mind it's to change your
mind about what you think of the people
are thinking probably both but uh it's a
good point yeah you know the abalene
Paradox sounds really familiar but
really good I learned I learned about it
last week and now I can't I can't shut
up about it's one where everybody is is
it sort of like the can's beauty contest
where you're trying to figure out what
other people will think whoever other
people think is the most beautiful
person to to a degree yeah the abene
Paradox is a situation in which a group
makes a decision that is contrary to the
desires of the group's members because
each member assumes the others approve
of it it explains how a number of
accurate individuals can become idiots
when they get together think Emperor's
New Clothes an acquaintance invites you
to his wedding despite not wanting you
there because he thinks you want to
attend you attend despite not wanting to
because you think he wants you there at
a business meeting someone suggests an
idea uh the making the influence of the
face of the brand a trans influencer
each member has misgivings about this
but assumes that the others will
consider them transphobic if they speak
out so everyone approves the idea
despite no one liking it or basically
all of North Korea
yes
right I I I strong strongly suspect that
you've you've got five or 10% True
Believers in North Korea at least yes I
think you I mean I also have no doubt
that if you open the Border South Korea
a large majority of the population would
leave very quickly yeah yeah you had
this other tweet that I loved from a
while ago dear intellectuals if you ever
decide you've been deeply wrong for
years don't instantly Rebrand yourself
as a wise spokesperson for your new view
instead publicly admit that your
judgment clearly isn't very good and
stop pontificating for a few years why
yeah it is inspired by a few particular
people who remain nameless who did this
bizarre transformation from I start off
as the world's expert on this View and
now that view is totally wrong and
stupid and now I'm the expert on the
other VI like well if it's totally wrong
and stupid like what does that say about
the fact that you held it for for 10
years I mean I just think that you again
it's Lo while it's logically possible
that a person could just see through the
erors and become incredibly thoughtful
about a new view I just think that it's
highly unlikely and this is more of
someone has either fame or money or both
on the line and therefore they can't
actually go through this honest period
of Contrition where they just say gee
like if I could be that right wrong what
would be a what would be a hypothetical
example of someone doing this hm I mean
one of my favorite ones is all of the
Rabid stalinists who deconverted and
then quickly claimed to be the leading
spokesman for anti-communism this is a
big deal in the 40s and 50s a Whitaker
Chambers comes to mind as one example
let's see who else Sydney hook let's see
there's a bunch of other ones uh let's
see um think Max eatman as well right so
you basically like you know like he was
a trus but anyway but you know they they
spend like years going and acting like
Joseph stellon as a savior of mankind
and then it's like oh but uh turns out
he's a horrible mass murderer whoops
okay now I'm gonna go and tell everybody
how to be an anti-communist I mean on
the one end like if you have specific
things you've observed then fine say
like I actually saw The Killing Fields
so listen to me I was but but on the
other hand to say but now I'm the expert
on how anti-communism should work no I
think we should probably listen to the
people who never thought it was a good
idea and were preent I mean I will say
that I am I especially have it out for
Whitaker Chambers who wrote a totally
unfair review of ir Ran's Atlas Shrug
here's someone who had who hated
communism from her teenage years when
she first encountered it never had a
good word to say about it I think had a
lot of insightful things to say about
how horrible it was and then Whitaker
Chambers has the nerve to call her a
fascist in his review for National
Review like like that
guy you know you just want to say you
know what you like there's a reason you
became a stalinist which is that you
don't have a correct attitude about how
to think about ideas and how to treat
other human
beings it's the sort of performative
empathy or I guess social desirability
bias sort of wrapped up in a a world
where your your words are more important
than your Deeds which they certainly are
now but they are basically at any
distance right because we can't see what
you're doing but we can read what you
wrote or hear what you said um and yeah
this has got spun up
so much more recently where you see lizo
you know is supposed to be this Champion
for bigger bodied women but it turns out
that she's fat shaming all of her dances
backstage and making them eat bananas
out of the vaginas of Amsterdam
strippers uh Ellen degenerous or I I
have no knowledge of any of this I'll
take your word for it I promise you it's
true it promise you there's videos out
there um and yeah my point being that
it's often the people that proclaim the
loudest about a thing that are the ones
that are the worst
uh people committing that that
particular
misgiving right this reminds me of a
couple of other essays that I have I
have one called you know could such a
man care and it just starts with all
right you go and you hear the official
the official speeches of Kim jongan or
Maduro and it's all about how I'm such a
great compassionate person I love the
people I have the poor I'm a champion
and at the current stage in their career
you're like yeah sure we know what
you're really doing what you're up to
but then you go back in time and realize
there was some earlier period when they
didn't have power and they couldn't
really go and do horrible things and
they were just but they were still going
and expressing the same ideas Kim
jong-un's not a good example because
he's born into this but Maduro is a
perfectly fine example but anyone who
starts off as a non-politician an
activist and then they eventually get it
you can go and find what they originally
saying and say all right well like and
like you know one reaction is well
obviously they were really corrupted by
power or whatever but you know my
reaction to this is look think about the
nicest people that you know in real life
could you imagine that they would become
Mass murderers if you put them in charge
I like like no like the nicest people I
know like like they might they probably
get overthrown or assassinated but they
would not be ordering anyone to be
killed they're just too nice to do that
kind of thing and so when you look at
someone who has power and they and they
have all of this wonderful altruistic
rhetoric and they had it for a long time
and you say well they got corrupted no
much better story is they were always
terrible they were always the kind of
person that was going and just telling
people what they want to hear
demagoguing exploiting social
desirability bias to gain power and once
you realize that it's like H the fact
that people are saying this kind of
Flowery altruistic talk there's a good
reason to go and distrust those people
because it's just so common for them
when they get power to be
terrible I love it Brian Kaplan ladies
and gentlemen Brian where should people
go they want to keep up to date with
everything you're doing uh great
question so all of my books uh so the
main ones we talked about today were
don't be a feminist as well as how evil
or politicians and voters as mad
scientists those are about all my books
are available on Amazon these books of
essays are real cheap just 12 bucks I
haven't raised the price despite High
inflation I also blog for bet on it and
finally I still have a personal web page
at
bca.com awesome Ryan I appreciate you
thank you fantastic being here it's been
a lot of fun if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe